find out on this episode of
exposing Darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us today on LED live today
actually is live usually we do a lot of
pre-recorded premieres and stuff like
that but today is a special day because
a lot of people are celebrating
Halloween so I know a lot of people are
watching scary movies horror movies and
you know we don't we don't talk a lot
about horror movies on this channel
because it's pretty obvious if it's
horror movie it's full of violence and
the Occult and things like that a lot of
murder and stuff but we have a guest on
our show today her name is Mia she's got
a lot of what what are you what do you
do I am a mental health first aid
instructor and I also am a mental health
coaching consultant awesome so it's
awesome to have you on the show because
we're going to actually be talking about
your brain on scary movies so what
happens to your mind when you watch
these movies does anything happen is it
just entertainment does it affect us in
any kind of way we talk about this stuff
all the time on this show we actually
have a full-length documentary called
pseudology if you want to check that out
it's it uh the whole documentary comes
from the aspect of science psychology we
removed completely the spiritual aspect
of it because we want it to be something
you can show a skeptic like hey I'm not
I'm not a Christian I don't believe in
that anyway well here's just the raw
scientific facts what happens to your
brain when you're being entertained by
these things so this is actually a
presentation that you've put together so
let's assume that first slide is here
mental health is really big right now a
lot of people have questions and they're
wondering like why is all of a sudden
everybody depressed or why are there so
many people experiencing anxiety so the
fact that we all are taking the time to
just kind of look deeper into this
especially from that media lens I think
they're so relevant and so important and
so one of the big questions that came
out for me is you know I Was preparing
for this is like why do people like
scary movies you know and that's a
really big one because for me someone
whose life has been a scary movie like I
was telling you all my story about you
know just being a survivor of rape and
Trauma and even my own sister actually
being abducted and so I'm so grateful
that we got my sister back but when I
think about scary movies for me it's
like this isn't fake this is real people
are actually living these stories you
know what I mean and it's it's crazy to
see how they don't think about the
families of the people when they're
reenacting a lot of these movies that
you're seeing it's not just out of their
brain these are stories that they've
researched and pulled together of
people's real horror things that
actually happen yeah like what you're
saying is I'm identifying with that too
because a year ago we lost our daughter
wow and we were you know you see media
and stuff I don't we don't really sit
down and watch a lot of stuff but you go
to people's houses and you see it and
there's a comedy on and somebody drops
dead and it's like supposed to be funny
and it's right there's nothing funny
about this right and it totally changed
my mind about that kind of stuff because
that would have been something that I
would have laughed about a year before
that you know right but uh yeah it's
different when you've lived it exactly
exactly I know I used to be obsessed
with horror movies I was Gothic metal
head all that all I did was watch horror
movies the more gruesome the better and
that's a good question like why are we
drawn to that I know you were into that
stuff too right yeah I pretty much grew
up on scary movies yeah I watched them
since I was little so I don't really
think I ever considered the why I just
did it was just interesting
um just captivated my attention longer
um but I was afraid to sleep like in my
own bed yeah a lot of the time so it was
really scary absolutely absolutely well
this is really interesting and I just
want to read it for you guys so this is
coming from the research of it's called
the Journal of media and psychology and
they said basically there are actually
three reasons why people like scary
movies one you have tension which is the
shock Factor you know the idea of I'm
Gonna Be Afraid and that shock Factor
can actually be really addicting right
because you're getting adrenaline and
then you're afraid and then you're going
to get dopamine because you're feeling
better after the people that you care
about are safe right and then another
one which is really huge this one stuck
out to me was relevance right the idea
that I can relate to this right so I
remember being a Survivor it felt good
to know I wasn't alone I wasn't the only
person that had been abused or had been
harmed like and I don't want it to sound
weird but I know those who have
experienced the same thing this
resonates with you it's like you hear
that it happened and you're sad but then
you're like okay I'm not by myself you
know and so that relevance can sometimes
play a part where you know maybe on some
level our lives are connecting to the
scary movie and then lastly this one was
you know just unrealism some people are
literally entertained because it's fake
you know and it's like oh that's
hilarious how I already know this is
fake and it's just hilarious to see how
they're gonna play out the story and so
these are some of the three main reasons
that people can become you know just
love scary movies or like to watch it
it's interesting because some of these
are like Polar Opposites that's true I
can relate or this is completely fake
attention you know I can kind of see
that I was kind of like an adrenaline
junkie as a teenager and stuff and I
know I have a personal friend he's
Skydive like over 100 times and right
has got to be some kind of adrenaline
comes with that because you're like I
could die like this parachute might not
open up so yep yeah I
that's releasing something some kind of
dopamine in your mind you're right
absolutely and also the idea that you
know on some level you feel like oh I
can outsmart the bad guy I can you're
watching this movie and you're like oh
she just needs to go down that way
instead of this way you know and because
I thought of that and that was a good
idea you know there's a kind of reward
for it so you're getting a lot of
rewards as you're watching it and then
also even the idea that oh she went down
that way and that was a good idea and
then she's cute oh no you know even that
oh no that happened but then
um you're getting that relief too like
oh well I guess I was wrong and so it
kind of drags you in and keeps you there
like the plot twist yes exactly all
right so how does that work with
um like because most scary movies have
twists at the end that's right so
usually you have like the nice beautiful
music everybody's happy and then like
the screen starts panning a little bit
and then you see something lurking so
what do you like know why they do that
in movies is it to reel you into the
next scene like series or
right right so that's really good like
um and this next part is talking about
why are the scary movies bad for you and
that element that you're bringing up is
perfect in fact you know that screechy
sound
[Music]
I don't know that's the one I remember
from those but yeah exactly that's what
she's talking about yes yes so all of
this is actually intentional because now
it's activating your primitive brain as
they call it you know that brain that
gets into the fight or flight right that
the part of that's meant to protect you
and to help you and to remember when
things are unsafe so that it can try to
keep you safe and so what's happening is
that your prefrontal cortex that whole
Space there is being bypassed right and
they're using those sounds and things
like that to kind of get you into that
mindset that's true I mean if you hear a
a bug buzz by you're like and thinking
uh you know you hear a cat hiss or
something you know like oh dangerous
yeah it's ingrained in US yep absolutely
I was thinking of the movie The Exorcist
the first one I heard that there was a
lot of psychological stuff that they did
in that just doing the sounds Alone
um you know you watch a movie without a
score without a sound it looks
completely like fake and like cheesy but
with the music really builds a lot and
they said that in that movie they would
like shake up bees and make them angry
sounds and just they put all kinds of
sounds in there that would mess with
people's minds so they were purposely
psychologically messed with people oh
absolutely in fact I was looking at a
study that talked about The Exorcist
specifically and it talked about it was
one of the movies that had had the
highest shock factor for a long time
that jump scare it had it was one of the
highest you know they've had some that
have beat The Exorcist in later years
but it was um the idea of God giving us
that primitive brain you know that idea
that we we have to take care of
ourselves and when I say primitive
um you know that your your prefrontal
cortex is responsible for you know being
able to make decisions and make plans
whereas your primitive brain is more
like the instinctual brain and so like
imagine if you hear a baby crying we are
wired to respond you know and so even
some of those that
sound is partially that sound of what a
baby might sound like crying so you're
going to respond and you're going to
respond in a specific way right like
even when I made this sound I don't know
if you notice but your heart probably
started beating just a little bit faster
you know so like you could well I'm not
a thing to do this but you could test it
out and you would find it to happen yeah
so our our scary movie is actually bad
for you right right thank you for asking
that so
so this is my answer yes
and possible
like well first of all Yes
um scary movies they are desensitizing
right and um sometimes you see this
happen in therapy where it's called
aversion therapy the idea is to make
someone not like something right but
then you also have a sensitization where
you just you say the what happened to
you over and over and the idea is that
it no longer has its effect on you right
and so research researchers have seen
that this really happens when you're
watching a scary movie now the issue for
those of us who are Christian is that
hey I'm getting used to seeing someone
be stabbed to death you know what I'm
saying what does that mean for me
morally right
um what does it mean in terms of my
empathy you know what kind of empathy do
I have like that's just being like
turned off right and then another thing
is your health right due to health
reasons is one um issue that can really
okay think about this like a roller
coaster ride right a roller coaster ride
is really fine and part of it is because
you're like almost simulating being in a
car accident right and you're going to
have
um a physiological response to being on
that roller coaster well the same thing
is going to happen when you're watching
scary movies and some people have
actually died right and it's usually
honestly and it's not something that
would be just like it's not very common
for someone to die because they've been
on a roller coaster ride it's not really
common that you're going to die because
you watched a scary movie
however people who have underlying
health conditions are really at high
risk because now you have increased
blood pressure includes blood close
blood glucose levels and then you have
all these um your heart is pumping
faster right and so people have actually
had heart attacks depending that's
interesting you brother though because
rides they have the sign right there if
you're pregnant if you're exactly have
heart trouble don't ride this ride but
movies don't really come with that
warning but I'm starting to see they
kind of do now I'm starting to see a lot
of trigger warnings at the beginning of
things and even just like epileptic this
has a lot of strobing and stuff but the
trigger warning thing is Big something
you said on the what was the last slide
you went on there he said yeah the
empathy so I've I've experienced that
and that's how the people they get
people to overcome fears just face your
fears just hold this spider in your hand
and you won't be as afraid of it so what
is that doing like you said when you see
somebody being murdered over and over
and over you're not going to be fair
full of that saying that it's just gonna
maybe even entertain you and I remember
seeing this was years ago somebody was
like stabbed in in the middle of the
city and nobody reported it people
actually were watching it exactly and
and there was another case of a kid that
was a special needs kid that was
drowning and there was some teenagers
that were recording it and laughing
absolutely like imagine who in the right
mind responds that way somebody's dying
in front of you you don't laugh and
record it but that's where we've been
desensitized through things like jackass
I grew up on that like getting hurt is
funny right you know and and being
entertained by murder and stuff through
horror movies I definitely see the
danger in that well absolutely I mean
we've seen it where people have just
taken out their phones while someone is
being abused you know what I'm saying
and the idea isn't even I'm taking out
my phone to call 9-1-1 I'm taking out so
I can post this on social media but I
also believe that you know the news has
a big part to play in that too because
when a crime happens they're showing
more and more of it and it's no longer
considered distasteful and so there you
have that at desensitization of of your
response to problems I remember watching
there was a another article I was
looking at and you know how on scary
movies sometimes they always have that
grin right I don't know how to do it but
it's like the the scary I don't know how
to make my face do it but it's that
scary grin right and so there was in
this study they looked at different
monkeys and um the monkeys they were
trying to see how long it would take
before they respond to different types
of faces and so the face that it took
the longest to be desensitized to was
that grin that you see on those scary
movies where it's kind of like a smile I
think about that clown
yes like an evil smile and that's the
one that your brain actually took the
longest to actually become desensitized
to right it's like the brand new like
this is this is this is not right you
know and even though I easily got
desensitized to some of the other things
they were doing that grin and if you
think about it when you see it on a
scary movie it just evokes something
right so yeah wow so what you said I I
found an article if you skip ahead from
Psychology today and it says Martin 2019
in a review of 96 studies found that
increased pleasure and desire for
watching scary films were correlated to
less fear and less empathy so here's
Psychology today saying exactly what you
said that watching these movies and
being taking pleasure in them actually
desensitizes you you have less empathy
it says men appeared to enjoy horror
films more than women who are more
empathetic and more prone to anxiety and
disgust this is just naturally how we're
wired you know women are more like the
kid falls down the woman wants to go
over there and nurture them and the
dad's like you know rub some dirt in it
you know and can I even add to that
women are also going to be more likely
to be the victim of a crime that's true
yeah men are more likely to fight and
defend themselves says furthermore
individuals with higher manipulativeness
and deceitfulness scores exhibited
decreased sadness and disgust while
watching these movies not surprisingly
people with more anti-social personality
disorder traits and lower the preferred
graphically violent scary film so people
that have less empathy anyway they want
to see more and more show me more show
me more guts I Want To the Gory are the
better and here it said that people who
are
more deceptive in things they had
decreased sadness and disgust so
something that should make you sad
seeing somebody lose their life should
sadden you but they're not they're not
you know displaying any sadness at all
or disgust right all that should be
repulsive to us you know it's so true
and I was actually looking at another
article and it was saying I think this
was in Mayo Clinic it talked about how
people are actually more afraid of
psychologically scary movies than say
movies that are just like the scare
Factor like ah I popped out of a closet
but things that actually make you
imagine something bad happened things
that are actually more realistic more
likely to happen those had a greater
effect on people as well there's some
examples I mean I don't I'm not I didn't
grow up on scary movies and what were
some examples that um you know of that
are like psychological scary movies Men
actually I want to be like you you know
I don't have an actual example of
psychologically scary movies because
once I learned about little light and
your amazing work yeah I stopped
watching so many things and so I'm
really glad but um if I was to just go
off the top of my head one that used to
really scare me was Chucky and somebody
yeah yeah right like so Chucky coming
out of the closet and the way they would
set it up you know like I remember as a
kid because they have it set up like
this is your room I'm in your room this
is what a typical little girl's room
looks like you know and now boom
Chucky's coming out you know so yeah I
don't know children play with the doll
is now trying to murder you and yeah if
a kid gets exposed to that yeah and
they're gonna be scared to be in their
own room right that's actually where
um like for me watching movies like
scream or Chucky okay that stuff doesn't
scare me because it's like an actual
person trying to kill someone you're
desensitized yes I am so what I would
normally go for is like Insidious or The
Conjuring or the Boogeyman and those are
things out of the apparently funny like
like funny you say that because
paranormal like activity that movie did
not scare me like I was like man one
star you know but it's like things that
are more dealing with the spiritual
realm
um you don't really it's a weird
distorted figure
um it's just it has Supernatural powers
like that kind of stuff or the things
that really scared me and I think that
goes along the lines of the
psychological effect versus the ones
where it's just scream like it's like oh
no he's in your closet or Boogeyman he's
under your bed and it's just like I
don't know I got desensitized to those
really really quick can I say this at
least they sound like I don't know I
don't know if it sounds lame okay you
can tell me but a movie that actually
did scare me before I stopped watching
um movies was The Matrix actually
um to me that movie was scary in the
sense that this idea that there's some
alternate reality that you're not aware
of that's happening in the background
you know I feel like that messed with my
mind more and it made me question what's
going on around me and put me in a sense
of fear and what's going to happen and
so even though Matrix wouldn't be
classified as a scary movie that's kind
of what I'm speaking about too that you
know it's the reality of it or
psychologically what's going on that you
aren't aware of that you can't prepare
for because you can't even access that
Dimension that kind of thing you know I
want to say something real quick I have
some slides in here that's going to talk
about different serial killers that have
actually popped out from watching scary
movies but I excluded an example for the
Matrix because I thought it was uh that
wasn't really a horror movie so I'm not
going to include that one but there
actually has been in serial killers that
said I became a serial killer after I
watched The Matrix because the of how it
was presenting violence and stuff and I
thought huh that's not a good example so
I threw it out but that's interesting
you should say that yes yes absolutely a
good example of like a psychological
thriller or something sci-fi because
yeah if you didn't know that you were
being used as some human battery and
you're in a pod can you know creating
energy for aliens or whatever that's
exactly pretty crazy to think about
so did you have no okay so um was there
a slot of yours before this
um let's see no oh I think so this is
just talking
for those
like myself and you're like okay what's
happening my brain exactly you know just
um sharing this with you it says that
scary movies they bypass the conscious
parts of your brain and tap directly
into your fight or flight response okay
and a lot of people we've heard about
the amygdala and stuff like that but
basically this is just letting us know
that um your brain the part of your
brain that's responsible for seeing if
things look like a threat and so it's
pumping oxygen into your muscles in case
you need to fight and run and so we
pretty much know all those different
things but all of this is actually
happening while you're watching a scary
movie and in fact man I was actually
just listening to something on my way
here and it was saying how in the future
movies are going to look different even
horror movies they're getting to the
place where now you're going to be able
to put on a device and based on how you
physically respond to it like whether
you jerk or Flinch or what what kind of
parts of your brain actually light up in
the fmri scan they will know now what
type of it's kind of like choose your
adventure type of thing like oh this
part of your brain lit up in the fmri
and so now this is what's going to
happen in the movie and it was it was
amazing yeah so if you see somebody
coming here and you turn now they're
going to insert something else over here
behind you or something and they were
saying it like the new editor the new
editors or Publishers of movies aren't
going to be the film writers it's going
to be the person watching it pretty much
and they're going to be doing it on
based on how your brain responds have
you seen those AI videos that they
create and it zooms in and it creates
different characters and stuff yeah
there's a artificial intelligence can
create pictures oh but now it creates
videos and it can zoom in so it can make
a picture I saw one of Hell the guy
wanted to know how look like and so you
see like all this fire and stuff and it
zoom zoom zooms but as it's zooming in
it's creating more stuff it's like
endless creation coming at you and it's
just like this endless Zoom thing which
is a huge problem yeah it's a huge
problem because our brains no no
different you know like our brain the
reason our brains are responding we're
we talked about the oxygen and the
amygdala is because the brain knows no
different it's not looking at this and
saying oh it's a movie because that part
of the brain has been bypassed right
it's it's actually responding as though
this is really happening to me so yeah
to prove your point there the next slide
from medium.com totally not a Christian
website at all so there's no bias this
is completely secular sources and it
says it's not just a movie that's what
we hear all this I was just a movie I
don't even know what that means it's
just a movie so it can show terrible
things in it but it's not just a movie
how television shapes our brains
television puts us into a hypnotic State
wow what does that mean for us
it says movies and television shows
allow us to vicariously experience lives
far removed from our own from tragic
love stories to historical epics we peek
into another world but we're not
actually experiencing it right and then
highlighted here it says while we may
not be physically entrenched in our
favorite film research from neuroscience
and psychology suggests that movies and
television can impact us just as much as
real life experiences scientists have
long known that television can affect
children's verbal physical cognitive and
emotional development absolutely does it
say physical wow really physical
cognitive and emotional development how
can a movie have this much power on our
development because movies and
television can penetrate our
subconscious mind the content can
Inspire Challenge and heal our psyche or
heal our psyche so depending on what
you're watching exactly some things can
be beneficial I I've talked about this
before on the show but I remember
watching a collage of people doing kind
acts of kindness watching with my
daughter
and there's like 10 things where people
were given uh helping the homeless and
things like that and it really inspired
me like after that movie or after the
little show I was like Lily let's go do
something like I really want to do that
and I was like imagine if television as
much as I hate censorship and all that
imagine if we lived in a world where
only acts of kindness were shown on
television that's your only option to
watch that or go experience real life
but how different would the world be man
that's powerful and when I think about I
think about
um role playing and modeling you know
like and it's power and making Pathways
in our brain so that we will learn how
to respond in ways right and so we can
when we think about role play role play
you're going to teach me how to be more
assertive let's say right and so you I
will be you you'll be me and you act out
the idea that hey this is what it would
look like to be more assertive if you're
being bullied right so that's a good
thing but in these movies especially
when we're talking about scary movies
and horror let's consider that this idea
of role playing is actually happening as
well and where you're going to learn
certain behaviors and responses your
brain is actually going to make these
Pathways and patterns which you all do
great work talking about that as well
that this is how I'm going to respond if
this happens and because it bypassed
right this is going into this is my
automatic response of how I'm going to
do this that or the other I'm sitting
here thinking of video games all the way
oh man video games are huge absolutely
um yeah I wanted to know
um
so the amygdala the purpose of it is to
detect fear it's like gives us that
response to fear so is there
I guess is it possible that when you're
watching scary movies
you get this fear response but then
you real like you remember that it's
fake could that ever impact you in a
real life scenario where like if you're
just sitting in front of TV all the time
just watching like you know you get
scared and then you realize it's fake
and you're just watching it happen to
somebody else does your brain ever get
to the point where if you were in a
situation like that in real life let's
say somebody was chasing you would it
ever I guess decide to not respond
because you're being chased right or
just kind of I don't know shut down a
bit while it's a really great question
um I want to talk about it from this way
I think about like so you talked about
video games and we talked about like
looking at the scary movies I think
about the power of muscle memory as well
right so we know that's happening
because of the different Pathways in our
brain so imagine if we're watching
something
um we're going to be trained on how to
respond so in the movie If I understand
your question correctly most times we're
being trained really on how to respond
to something that's happening or we're
being conditioned right to not respond
which is what I hear you saying I could
see that definitely happening where
maybe we walk into a situation that
should feel dangerous or should feel um
inappropriate and yet because we've been
desensitized to it we don't have that
response now whether or not you will no
longer do that primitive brain and do a
fight flight freeze or Flop that is a
really good question I'm not really sure
it'll probably depend on the individual
and how much their brain has been
damaged Honestly by the things that
they're allowing themselves to do when I
think about video games that muscle
memory right your your brain is learning
shoot shoot you know like stab run jump
out of the window whatever you know and
so it's it's being automatically primed
for those types of things it reminds me
of that news article I heard about that
kid that kid that got arrested put in
jail they put us at him right beside the
deputy and then he because he said I
played Grand Theft Auto we took the guys
took the deputy's gun shot him shot the
other guy and got out of the thing he
said how did you learn to do that how
did you learn to hey decide you're going
to grab the guy's gun and get out of
there he said oh I've been playing games
yeah I've been playing video games yeah
and imagine the like when it's a virtual
reality and you're moving your hands
talk about muscle memory you know you're
doing this now here's another example
when I was out I lived out in Hawaii for
about three years uh big big time
militarized area out there I had friends
that would come and go constantly and
one of my buddies uh that was he was
younger his dad had come to us and said
hey would you let him stay with you I
want him to have good influence and
everything he was he was maybe 17-18 and
I said sure as long as you since he's a
minor stay with him too so they rented
two rooms for me it was a big house we
had a rented area out there so I sublet
to them and they um and and I remember
his son played games 24 7. I mean just
all the time every day yeah he said can
I set up the garage I want to have a
gaming Center down there I said sure set
up the garage down there and so he set
up the garage played games and when he
turned 18. the military came and they
said because you're so good at the
controller we're going to have you fly
drones uh what he got a job buying
drones for the military yeah because he
had programmed his brain so well to
react right in war situations exactly
and I mean it makes me think about
simulations right isn't that what the
Air Force does the Army does as a
soldier you're going to go through
simulations before you are out there on
the field on how you are to respond
starting from here in a particular
situation so yeah people spend hours a
day playing a murder simulator a flight
simulator not a driving simulator but a
murder simulator yeah the article
continues
um on the next slide or is this the next
one the I think this is the next one
okay yeah it says
movies and television put you into a
hypnotic State now this is not little
light talking this isn't right Christian
bias yeah science here movies and
television put you into a hypnotic state
within seconds of turning on the TV our
brain waves lower to an alpha state
which is where we are most
impressionable the information we see or
hear on the television whether it's the
news or a fiction film works on our
subconscious mind what does that mean
what we believe so what we believe how
we perceive the world and ourselves our
values our aspirations all of this can
be reconfigured by what we watch on TV
come on like people this is science dude
you cannot deny this stuff has been
studied now scientists know that these
changes occur on a neurological level
watching TV can change how much we use
certain brain areas and how these brain
regions develop exactly for example
watching more TV can increase the size
of the visual cortex and the sensor
monitor sensor motor sensor motor core
tea course cortices
however it can also negatively impact
the activity of the frontal the front
front of polar regions of the brain
which is associated with intelligence
exactly your intelligence as disturbing
as this may sound watching TV isn't all
bad it can also expand our EXP
experiences when we go into a hypnotic
State and so this is huge because as
you're reading that article a few things
are jumping out to me right so in the
mental health space right now hypnotism
is getting huge it's really big and you
know this is a problem a lot of times
when you see people that are
specializing in hypnotism number one
they say that anybody can hypnotize you
and so there's no medical research
backing this for real they'll come up
with okay I shouldn't say it like that
what I should say is
um they will have
um research that backs and says that
well based on the experiences of these
people you know these were the outcomes
and we do see hypnotism having a
quote-unquote positive effects on people
so people have had pain relief because
of hypnotism they've been able to have
childbirth without pain because of
hypnotism and so this looks like a good
thing but one of the biggest things
they'll say in the mental health space
is no one can be hypnot ties unless you
allow it no one can be hypnotized unless
you choose it you can only be hypnotized
if you do but here this article is
showing us that this can happen without
you even being aware you know and now
that is a huge problem because when
you're tapping into your subconscious
mind this is where you're going to it's
going to be like a um imagine a a ladder
right and so you have your primitive
brain at the bottom we're not we're in a
dollhouse okay so you have your um you
have your primitive brain at the bottom
and you have your um your what you call
your Intel it's called your intelligent
brain at the top right that's your
prefrontal cortex making decisions
making plans reasoning all of that is
there and in between this staircase here
um you have basically that I'm going to
call it like your that subconscious
space that connects it to right and what
can be happening when you're being
hypnotized is Imagine like a little
child you know the those little dividers
what they call them when you don't want
your child to go somewhere and you like
put the little gate down okay so now
hypnosis was kind of cutting that off
right and now we're able to like kind of
suggest whatever we want to go in there
but the problem is your prefrontal
cortex isn't able to assess it and
decide whether or not this is what we
want this is what is good for us is the
outcome and so it can be very dangerous
and I believe believe that that is a big
reason why we do see people deciding to
create
um to
do acts of murder pretty much you know
like you said in the story with the
young man because that gate isn't there
yeah like we're all of us here or the
gate is there or isn't there depending
on the situation yeah right so we we
talk a lot about
um
guarding the Avenues of the soul but not
putting things in front of your mind and
and so it can happen unexpectedly I mean
I can be watching some
great research or a sermon on YouTube
and all of a sudden add three two one
pop and all of a sudden you see
Victoria's Secret on the screen yeah I
didn't choose to put that in front of my
face but because now my eyes have seen
it I can't get that out of my mind now
it's been in
um and printed on my mind if you will
and so yeah when you're watching movies
even if you're willfully going into that
theater you don't know what's going to
happen that's exactly kind of the whole
point of going you don't want spoilers
don't tell me what's going to happen
right and and you're exposing yourself
to all that stuff
and it's definitely having an effect
yeah yeah and I would even say um and I
wish I could remember the name of this
but there was like an inspirational
story I remember that came out it was
supposed to be a Christian story
um and in this story
um the child goes into the forest and
unfortunately they're murdered and the
whole point of the story is the father
coming to forgive the people that did
this but I remember feeling really
traumatized by it you know what I'm
saying um and the I mean I'm sure that
that happened because of our situation
with our family it was a real thing that
you know happened to our family except
that we got my sister back but on top of
that watching that movie
um it kind of put in your mind what this
would be like you know you kind of like
reliving it and while
um some associations are going to say oh
when you watch movies when you watch
scary movies it's not going to cause you
to have PTSD but imagine people who are
suffering from PTSD now coming in and
watching it and a lot of times people
who suffer from PTSD they don't realize
until they're triggered you know and
something happens they're like oh my
goodness and they're taken to that place
that place of Darkness or fear where
things happen for them you know I want
you to remember that PTSD because
there's a slot in here that kind of goes
into that but yeah let's see medium
container continues on this article
and the next one and it says some
experts say movies can function as a
sort of Cinema therapy for healing and
growth because movies and television can
penetrate our subconscious mind the
content can Inspire challenge or heal
our psyche in in other words movies can
change the way we think and feel
for the better or for the better so
they're saying for the better but also
for the worst absolutely that's implied
there right they're especially useful as
an emotional release you can ask
yourself do I want this material to be
imprinted in my subconscious mind along
the same lines of recent study
determined that movies and television
shows can help people with attachment
issues watching healthy stable
relationships in a hypnotic State can
make people feel more connected with
others and subconsciously imprint the
beliefs that healthy relationships are
possible another recent study similarly
found that watching movies can challenge
our stereotypes and beliefs characters
can humanize a group of people a
political or social issue or an event
especially when we identify with the
characters so yeah that's that's what I
always say when people say it's just a
movie it doesn't affect me then why is
there such an outcry for
um
uh
getting people on the on the screen
what's it called for representation
right we wouldn't have any crowd for
representation if it's just a movie and
it doesn't affect it it doesn't change
anything but they're saying it can you
know it can open your mind about
stereotypes and this and that it can
change your beliefs absolutely and
marketing too yeah why is there such a
big eye cry for marketing why is
marketing such a big uh and uh big bucks
industry right because what you see
affects you you can you can make you buy
things it can make you do things yeah
and it really makes me question
um because we start up you know there's
an agenda you know there's an agenda
that can be in place so we do see mental
health issues on the rise like the
statistics say one in five people is
actually battling with the mental health
disorder or a mental health disorder and
that's across age ranges like we're
talking as young as three years old all
the way to the elderly population right
one in five people and honestly that was
a pre-covered statistic and so it really
makes you wonder when we're talking
about media and we're talking about what
your being hypnotized to believe and to
see and to feel if this is so positive
why aren't we seeing a healing of the
community a healing of people's hearts
and Minds we're actually seeing more
fear more selfishness more behaviors
being modeled that are being being
replicated into society and they are
deleterious they're harmful look at the
trends of what is in the media this is
saying if you see a healthy relationship
it can give you hope about that but how
often do you see that yeah I mean I can
just walk by the red box and it's like
horror horror horror dark comedy it's
like it's also dark and violent
everything's coming out even kids now
have there's a horror genre for kids
there's cartoons out there that are
horizontal for kids and so more and more
of what we consume is negative
absolutely immoral or violent so there's
a billboard in my community when you're
talking about horror violence and fear
and um you know the Billboards are
advertising jewelry and so usually
you'll see a woman looking you know you
know like she's so important or
beautiful in the jewelry or like look at
me right like this high class but I
noticed that the billboard that was near
our home the lady had on pearls but she
looked afraid like her face was
literally like like don't come near me
kind of face and her eyes were even a
little red but she was advertising this
pearl necklace and so it stood out to me
like why does Fear look attractive a
woman afraid looked attractive to you
know advertise this um necklace and so
we can definitely see that our minds are
being changed those of us who are
deciding to continue
um watching things that are harmful
it's going to have an effect uh I I read
a whole article one time about
subliminal messaging and it's proven
fact this isn't conspiracy theory
they've done it for years and years but
um they would always use Sex and Death
and I was like I don't understand death
or skulls like they would I saw a map of
um
there was an article it was an ad for a
cigarette ad and they showed okay we
want a skull on the cloud over here we
went uh his silhouette to look like he
has a pointy like they made his hair
point a little bit so it kind of
Associates with the devil and these
things and and the two there was a
couple there facing each other and they
had cigarettes in their hands but they
were they looked like sharp objects they
were facing each other and they said
it's supposed to psychologically make
you think that these two are going to
kill each other and there's a sunset in
the background but the sun was actually
setting into the water not behind the
water so it gives you an idea that the
end of the world was happening and I was
like I don't understand why death is a
selling point I can understand the sex
and all that but I I read that it's
supposed to the ad is supposed to put
you in a state of
of panic if this is the end but this
product is going to make me feel good so
it's like I gotta have that cigarette
now because I'm in this state of fear
and this is going to make me feel good
or whatever and so I don't know if that
goes with that pearl necklace thing but
right this article continues I think
and it's it finishes up by saying if
movies can challenge our stereotypes
this is in the highlighted part if
they can also create or install them if
movies can provide an emotional release
they can also stir up negative emotions
I love how unbiased this is experts
recommend watching movies and TV shows
strategically most importantly watching
too much TV has negative cognitive
consequences as mentioned earlier
excessive television consumption can
decrease our intelligence let's say that
again it can decrease our intelligence
when we do watch TV it's critical to
consume quality television movies and TV
shows that add emotional and mental
richness to our lives are the best you
can ask yourself do I want this material
to to be imprinted in my subconscious
mind I think that's something that we
should all be asking ourselves
what does the Bible say whatever things
are pure or lovely right you know Joy
focus on these things but to stay away
from the very appearance of evil
I think that's a no-brainer when it
comes to horror movies should I should I
watch it does it appear to be evil right
does it bring you closer to God in any
kind of way and I don't think that these
are just some arbitrary rules that are
from some tyrannical dictator in the sky
he cares about
all of us and if we're watching things
like this we're going to lose empathy
for each other right we're going to be
more likely to act out in violence in
these things and God doesn't want that
he wants a world of love and when I hear
you say that you know my mind goes in
two ways because it's one I hear what
you're saying to the person who remember
those three reasons why people look at
scary movies like if you're the person
who's like I'm just you know it's
unrealistic to me you know it's just
entertaining then question that you know
like why is it entertaining to you what
what is it that makes it funny right but
then if you're the person that relates
to it right you're that person that's
like man there's something about this
that speaks to me then I would really
encourage you to look into that in the
sense of you know connecting with
someone that can help you better look at
your thoughts objectively and say like
has there been a trauma in your life has
there been something that's happened
that causes you to connect or resonate
with this to long for this or desire it
like I remember when I was going to do
my healing journey I had so much anger
you know and so thinking about like I
don't know this is kind of an aside but
football when there did that contact
sport you know I was like yes boom
because in my mind I was thinking about
my
um the person that harmed me that I want
them to be crushed you get what I'm
saying um and sometimes you'll see this
in scary movies as I'm told like I like
I said praise God for a little light I
haven't watched in so long but um I
remember the idea of you know this
person is being punished in a horrible
way yeah that's great you know and so
yes finally Justice is being served and
that felt good to me because I felt that
the people that harmed me or my sister
had gotten away with it and so there was
like a relatability there there was a
connection that needed to be healed and
that's what was drawing me to watch or
participate in things that weren't
healthy and I'm just thinking of the
Bible when you talk about
um relating I mean the Bible doesn't
omit the bad parts that's right people
like these stained glass window of
people that we think about the apostles
like they had to Peter denied Christ you
know David a man of God's Own Heart uh
had a woman's husband murdered and he
took her in adultery like it doesn't
omit the bad parts and we can identify
with probably anyone in there someone in
there but there's always the Redemption
story that's right and that's what these
movies don't do it's like right like
like Britney said at the end do you
think oh happily ever after but there's
Jason popping up out of the water in the
end and um same thing people try to
justify Billy eilish they're like oh
because of her it helped me because I
was depressed and and I can identify
with her okay but is she giving you any
hope right see that's where I identify
with other people like Jeremy Camp who
right he married a girl with terminal
illness thinking that she was going to
be healed and she died and he wrote a
lot of music from that pain and the
music was always God knows he knows how
you feel he's walked that suffering and
so yeah you get to hear okay somebody
been through something that I can relate
to or maybe worse exactly but the
Redemption is we have a God that can
sympathize we have a god who's going to
redeem us and there's going to be
justice but it vengeance is his yes
that's really good and we don't have to
look to those things for an escape as
well there are tools that we can
actually use that improve our mental
health that can help us want to show up
in our real lives and actually be
helpful to others so I found these
articles on screen crush it was talking
about horror movies and the actors that
were on them and it said even though an
actor's Stellar performance is often
rewarded with critical praise and
sometimes even Awards the emotional
damage from taking on a difficult role
can last anywhere from a couple weeks to
several years wow so these actors are
seriously dedicated to their craft and
it definitely shows in the finished
product but the thing is once you tap
into those parts of yourself it's
difficult to snap back to your normal
self sometimes it even takes
Professional Therapy to fully move
forward from the project and then so
Shelley Duvall was one of the some of
them were not horror movies so I picked
ones that were horror but Shelley Duvall
played in The Shining and it said the
Vault has opened up about the physical
and mental anguish that the production
caused for her and this is her quote but
after a while your body Rebels it says
stop doing this to me I don't want to
cry every day and sometimes just that
thought alone would make me cry she told
Hollywood Reporter to wake up on a
Monday morning so early and realize that
you had to cry all day because it was
scheduled I would just start crying so
her body and I was just like impulsively
cries wow Kyle Richards and Halloween
she was actually in this as a as a young
child said later at the premiere so she
was when you're filming a movie it's all
out of order you're not seeing the big
picture right later at the premiere she
and a friend watched the movie for the
first time and full she says it was
obviously not child appropriate and we
were both traumatized she told Hollywood
or Halloween Daily News seeing it for
the first time all pieced together was a
very very different movie it was just
really scary and I really did sleep with
my mom until I was 15 years old after
that wow I was terrified so when you're
talking about whether you have PTSD
before you watch it or does it cause it
I would say this caused PTSD right she
was in the movie in the movie and and it
was fine because I'm sure she was just
in a scene where she's in a living room
or whatever but when she watched it she
couldn't even sleep at night she had to
sleep with her mom until she was 15
years old a girl that Kyle Richardson
Kyle Richards who played in the movie
Halloween Halloween maybe Kyle is a guy
that showed a picture of a girl but um
in the next slide here
as another example Janet lay from the
movie Psycho said I stopped taking
showers and I only take baths she
revealed the New York Times via the
Vintage news it's perfectly
understandable that Lee would want to
avoid showers because in that movie she
was murdered in a shower as they serve
as a psychopath as a psychopathic
psychological trigger but what about
when she's staying somewhere that
doesn't have a bath readily available
she answers when I'm someplace where I
can only take a shower I make sure the
doors and windows of the house are
locked she explains see now this is
traumatized a person for their whole
life I was in a movie about I was in a
shower and I got murdered now I can't
take showers and if I have to I'm going
to be a paranoid schizophrenic and
locking everything because you've
traumatized your entire life right and
see and that goes back to what we were
talking about the brain knows no
difference right like you're acting this
out you're having to reduce the emotions
and the feelings of what it would be
like to be murdered in a shower and then
you're seeing that the brain knows no
difference it's like okay this is what's
happening she's reacted as if this
happened to her exactly if somebody
really was in a situation where
someone's trying to kill you in the
shower you would be traumatized the same
way yeah and
um
it's innate with this because actually
there was a movie that I had watched a
horror movie called The Grudge
super scary at least when I watched it
right it was really scary and it's just
like those paranormal the long damp hair
like bluish skin doing the spider walks
bones cracking type of character right
and I remember there was a scene where
the main character was taking a shower
and then when she was washing her hair
she just felt like the hand there and
then she would just see like all like it
was just so crazy and I literally from
seeing that movie
anytime I was going to watch scary movie
I had to take a shower before then right
and I had to turn off the scary movie
and watch something like SpongeBob or
something like that after 5 p.m right
like it was just so terrifying but yeah
I I resonate with that there were just
some scary movies that they stick with
you you can't go like I I used to for
longest when I would turn off the light
downstairs and run up like I would run
up the stairs because just that period
of Darkness like what if something's
gonna chase me yeah you know so it just
really it stays with you it's true I
remember at the end this might date me
but watching Freddy Krueger movies and
it was always the you know when you lay
in the bed something happens to you
while you're in the bed and it's
disgusting blood flying up on it and so
I'd be afraid to like lay down you know
because I'm like oh what's gonna happen
while I'm sleeping on this vid and the
the brain knows a little different it
believes it to be so you know and so
some people really have to
um get cognitive behavioral therapy or
other other types of therapy to be able
to really heal from that yeah that's
definitely PTSD there's a thing here
from Brad yeah no let me talk about this
this is fascinating I pulled up a few
examples real quick from everyone's
heard Jeffrey Dahmer right Jeffrey
Dahmer was a serial killer in the U.S I
think he was in the US he was getting
more publicity and more publicity and he
said that he watched several movies were
his favorite he says the The Exorcist
three the Gemini killer and he also
walks watched The Exorcist one and two
were also his favorite interestingly
enough he he liked a few other movies
too like the Matrix but he said The
Exorcist was Exorcist three was a
favorite the thing that caught him and
we did a short an LED short about this
that thing had that caught him was that
um
the next person he was going to kill ran
out of his apartment he said he was
watching The Exorcist when this whole
thing started happening because he would
show The Exorcist to his his people
before they would kill him so that's
that's one I mean that so he said he
liked these movies and that would
trigger him to kill people that's just
one so we think maybe Jeff was just one
person that would that was uh that would
be interesting this is an example
Jeffrey Dahmer was uh was starting to
get into the movie so he wasn't
concerned about the other other cuff he
started this crazy motion sitting and
rocking back and forth and making these
strange noises like talking in tongues
that's what would happen when Jeffrey
would watch this movie that's straight
up possession bro yeah and that's what I
was thinking too that movie is really
scary too so the next one next slide I
have this this is another uh killer
it's documented that Martin Bryant
Australia's worst serial killer who
killed 35 people in 1996 was observed
was obsessed with Child's Play movies
that's Chucky right yeah so he namely
the bill in Chucky he was obsessed with
the child's uh like a childlike
characteristics of the doll and its
vengeful tactics it was even submitted
to the psychiatrist psychiatrist and
that the character was a major
contributing factor to Bryant's Massacre
I mean this is this is documented
evidence this isn't just you know what
hearsay here's some other examples
American school shootings in the mid 90s
were influenced by The Dream sequence in
Leonardo DiCaprio's The Basketball
Diaries I don't know what that is I've
never heard of that not a horror movie
but not a horror movie it's interesting
though um where he dressed in a trench
coat black trench coat and enters a
school room and begins to shoot
according to the true TV 14 year old
Brian I'm not going to say his last name
uh can I can't address in a long coat
entered his algebra class and Moses like
studying Washington and basically killed
a bunch of people that's interesting
because that sounds just like the
Columbine shooters exactly and they
blamed the Matrix and Marilyn Manson and
doom was a video game but yeah that's
like playing out the exact scene in a
school a school shooting wearing a
trench coat that's wow I'm not going to
skip these last two paragraphs if people
can read them that's fine but it's just
more more drama about that exact same
scenario
one of the other movies uh one of the
other um uh inspired uh genres or movies
was Natural Born Killers that movie is
demented yeah that had Woody Harrelson
in it and it was
there was decapitation everything it was
terrible yeah another student all right
so so check this out another student who
knew uh Lou contentious how do you say
that
said that the the shooter had thought it
looked like a fun to go murder a
murdering spree like the one in Natural
Born Killers
it's green everyone remember scream
right Scream the screen movies I mean I
I grew up that was a movie that came out
unfortunately I had seen that one that
was terrible they've made TV series of
it now it's still renewing itself I
remember watching that and going why did
I watch this this is terrible uh scream
has influenced murders and or murder
attempts as well
um he names a person that did murder uh
don a screen costume and stabbed another
person 30 times in England two teams
stabbed their friend I mean the list
goes on and on it talks about RoboCop it
talks about all this different stuff
that had happened it makes you wonder
are movies affecting us and what but
this is my real question
We Know by these examples that this
truly does affect other people right it
does truly affect serial killers to make
them kill
what about the other 90 of people 99 of
people whatever the statistic is that
don't
what is the difference maybe this is a
question for you what is the difference
between that and what what is it is it
just these people are more
um I mean we know what affects us all
right it affects everybody for example
this is a real life example and my
wife's allowed me to to tell this story
but uh she's when we decided we were
going to get some acreage and move out
of the country right my wife said
beautiful she said
I don't want to move out of the country
that's where murders happen
statistically if you look at it there's
more murders in Suburbia there's more
murders in the city than there are in
the country but what are the movies
portray exactly Wrong Turn yeah I've
seen that one too you know Saw movies
all this other stuff The Cabin in the
Woods is always yeah yeah and so she
said no we're not moving out I'm scared
to death about there well she had
unfortunately seen a lot of scary movies
growing up and that's what happened so
it affects everybody yeah but why does
it make some people murderers right
right man I wish I could answer that
question I would have to say I I'm not
able but what I can say is that we know
that we're being primed we know that
we're being conditioned we know that
we're being desensitized
um and and when it comes to mental
health we know that there are people who
have predispositions right there are
people who are going to be
predispositioned to depression and
anxiety and so we don't know what your
predisposition will activate can I put
it that way and I actually want to share
and this is a a really interesting fact
because we're thinking about you know
why does it affect some people and it
doesn't affect others I was actually
looking at this article about depression
and I just wonder if the information
will kind of shed light on what you're
asking and this says does depression
change your DNA so you know that's
really important to think about out
because your DNA makes up who you are
and the Legacy like the children your
children's children and your children's
children are all affected by your DNA
and your DNA can be being changed by
what you're doing and what's happening
and a lot of people don't actually
realize that but look at this it says
that um researchers from the UK have
found evidence that depression doesn't
just change our brains it can also alter
our DNA and the way our cells generate
energy okay this was in 2015 it says a
team from a well from the Welcome trust
Center for human genetics investigated
the genomes of more than 11 500 women
with the hopes of finding genes that
might contribute to the risk of
depression right they're trying to
answer that question like what cause why
why are some people at more risk for
depression than others that's what they
wanted to know it says but instead they
stumbled across a signature of metabolic
changes in their cells that appears to
have been triggered by have a disease
okay let's go on it says the most
notable Discovery was that women who had
stress-related depression that is
depression that is associated with some
kind of adversity during childhood now
just pause there we're talking about
um scary movies and horror movies and we
can have vicarious trauma you know we
didn't necessarily experience it but we
experienced it because someone else did
we saw someone experience it right
um or we heard about their experience
and we become traumatized by it okay so
let's continue depression that is
associated with some kind of adversity
during childhood such as sexual abuse
had more mitochondrial DNA than their
peers why is this important because the
mitochondria are the PowerHouse
organelles that provide the energy for
the rest of your cell and the increase
in mitochondria DNA led the researchers
to believe that the energy needs of
their sales had changed in response to
the stress so basically your body is
being changed due to the stress that
you're under does that make sense and
your energy requirements are becoming
different based on the stress that
you're under so this is really huge and
so we can see that structurally
something is happening to your very DNA
under certain levels of stress so it
causes me to think when you talk about
why do some people decide to become
murderers While others do not well we
don't know what's on their DNA we don't
know what predispositions that they had
okay let's look at this this is this is
huge it says after going back over their
results
the researchers also found that women
with stress-related depression had
shorter telomeres than the healthy women
telomeres are the caps at the end of our
chromosomes that naturally shorten as we
age and the team began to question
whether this process had been sped up by
the stress so basically the idea is that
you're actually aging
faster because of these telomeres does
that make sense because the telomeres
are talking about your aging they're
shortening and when they're shorter it's
because you're older and so people who
are having this experience their
telomeres are shorter they're aging
faster than maybe their peers or
counterparts does that make sense and so
really when we're and the reason I
brought this into this discussion is
because people are willfully watching
the horror movies and they're not
realizing what can be being triggered or
activated in their very DNA you know and
the scripture even tells us you know I
think you talked about it um guard your
heart without diligence for out of it
flows the issues of life and to me that
principle is talking about you know how
important it is to guard what you see
what you eat what you intake what's
happening because you don't know you
don't know how it's actually affecting
you even on a cellular level on a DNA
level and how this will even you know
you think oh it's just me it's only
affecting me I watched a scary movie
doesn't matter right like but we don't
realize is it possible and I'm just
asking the question is it possible that
you can actually you know the symptoms
that can come from watching these movies
right because it's talking about
depression but what symptoms can
actually be arising for a person that is
subjecting themselves to watching these
scary movies right when we talked about
that we talked about the health factors
what happens to your heart what's
happening to your body when you're
watching it are you talking about what's
happening to your mind and the idea that
I'm presenting is is it possible that it
could even be affecting your DNA I mean
like coming out of the gothic culture
myself like
people who were into that were into
horror movies and it comes with that as
depression as well so I I think if you
submerge yourself in poor all the time
you're probably going to have uh
depression and this is a different topic
but anime
um which is filled with a lot of horror
themes too but right there's a real
diagnosed thing now called post anime
depression
syndrome uh pads pads pads post anime
depression syndrome so it's really
diagnosed and it's really like you can
look it up and see what to do about it
or whatever but it's like people are so
obsessed with anime and into the story
that when the story ends they fall into
a depression like when you get to the
last you know final episode you fall
into a sense of depression because
you've become so attached to that
character and stuff and it's like your
best friend just died right and so just
go I'm only pointing that out to talk
about depression right media can
influence your mind yes to the point of
depression which can have DNA yeah
changes in your DNA
but isn't that um
a fruit to something else going on
because I know like when I was going
through depression I went to TV and
media because
I just want to get away from my life
right you know so yeah so it's like is
it scary movies that's the problem or is
it the reason behind why you're going to
scary movies that's the problem right
right I would say both I would I would
say that they're both the problem right
it's just like you know the reason that
I might turn to binge eating is because
of the issues of my life but the binge
eating is a problem as well you know
because of what it's doing to my body
exactly right and so the symptoms are
causing issues and I think it's really
serious and this is why for those of us
who you know maybe we've been thinking
about that we need help you know we need
to talk to someone but maybe we're
putting it off and instead going to
other ways of getting help like TV you
know what I'm saying and thinking well
at least I could just forget about
everything this is really serious this
is affecting potentially your
Generations you know and what I love
about mental health which is really in
the Bible is that recovery is always
possible you know I mean like if I have
damaged myself and I have you know what
I mean recovery is possible it doesn't
have to end like that God is my ultimate
movie writer you know what I mean and I
don't have to worry about Chucky coming
back you know what I'm saying like God
knows how to take down Chucky you know
and take him down for a good but I've
got to go to him you know and I've gotta
when it comes to my mental health don't
just think that oh I'll just pray it
away I may need tools tips and skills
you know to be able to recover you know
there may be patterns of thinking that
I've adopted from watching these movies
or other things in life maybe watching
my family that are toxic that need to be
helped and they can be from a Biblical
perspective yeah I thank you so much for
being a guest on here because you've
added so much that as out of our pay
grade or whatever
um do do you have you have a Ministry is
that something that people can reach out
to you and the Ministries here on the
screen it's pain unwasted I love that
title because
I've noticed that my whole life you know
you go through some trial and you think
like why is this happening to me and
it's painful in the in the process but
afterwards you come out with empathy you
do empathize you can sympathize with
people uh because you've been there and
so I love that because God can make all
things work together for good what Satan
means for evil that's right God can mean
for good so this is something people can
reach you on or whatever
yes exactly pain on wasted is our
organization that my husband and I
founded and basically we help people
basically to learn tips tools and
strategies on how to improve their
mental health but from a Biblical
perspective okay because a lot of times
as Christians we know that there's an
issue but we're concerned about who
we're talking to and what their
philosophy is going to be you know and
so we do that from a Biblical
perspective we um mainly engage High
performing professionals and
entrepreneurs but we do also do classes
and seminars for churches and schools
just being able to help people recognize
signs and symptoms and how to respond to
Pro freely because a lot of times people
see things but they don't know what to
do like how do I help this person what
am I to do that will be helpful and not
harmful and so we help train people
pastors teachers leaders in that realm
as well amen let's put that on the
screen again so people can see that this
is here's all the social media this is
the website and this is how you can
reach out to Mia's Ministry and we hope
that there's something on there that can
benefit you I hope that this episode was
eye-opening I hope that it was you
learned something if you want to see
more information like this we do have a
full-length documentary called
pseudology very informative it doesn't
even come from a Christian aspect just
the psychology the um
Messiah the pure science of it so we're
going to read some comments but I'm
going to go ahead and sign off we're so
glad you guys are here we love you and
we can't do this ministry without you
we'll see you guys next time on LED live